hope you were enjoying your lunch and
thank you for fighting your way through
another drizzly day to join us at our
youth ministry now gathering I don't
really understand what my traditions
understanding of apostolic succession
and laying on of hands is but whatever
powers have been vested in me by that
process I want to say retroactive grace
over our collective so join me in prayer
god of grace made known to us and
through Jesus the Christ home we thank
you for this opportunity to gather and
come together away from our reflective
tasks and studies and just be together
and in your presence celebrating the
calling that you've made on our lives
responding in faith we ask you to bless
our conversations and our gatherings
nurture friendships begun and continued
here bless this food and the hands that
prepared it we ask all this in Jesus
name Amen amen all right welcome i'm
just so glad you here and again we are
grateful for this collective effort both
the minister to our young and to
celebrate our callings and come together
and reflect on them as a community
gathered around the questions of youth
ministry i want to make just a couple of
introductions before we get on to really
an outstanding speaker who's traveled up
from Atlanta to join us in the first one
I want to introduce is Dean Joseph
Britain who is the Dean of the Berkeley
Divinity School and has been a partner
and collaborator and really door opener
for this venture from the beginning
so just to add a word of welcome both on
behalf of Berkeley Divinity School and
also Yale Divinity School the the
partnership between the two schools and
the Congregational Church in New Canaan
has been a really exciting and fruitful
one and we're glad to be a part of it
and I don't know if skips gonna say this
or not but you'll see around the room
some resources from the ministry
resource center in the library here you
may not know that the Yale Divinity
School Library has a very substantial
collection of materials that can be
useful to you all who are in parish and
congregational ministry and specifically
in youth ministry so do take a look at
what's available here and I know that
that's a part of what we can provide so
welcome and glad you're here and we'll
look forward to seeing you the next time
thanks thank you I do want to call your
attention to the resources and first I
want to introduce Carol and ingo heart
who is the director of the ministry
resource and it was when I was in
seminary here so it is a great and
venerable obedience in the same
direction so thank you any Carolyn
anything you want to say about the
materials and the resources go into the
library follow me if you're new to the
place and you need to go but we would be
glad to have you check out or talk with
us about resources similar to the one
scattered around the room we're here for
you here's a vision we haven't fully
realized but I but know that we're
working toward this I know how precious
your time were there isn't a single time
that I've been to any conference where
when i was driving there I I said to
myself I used to think I had time for
this what was I thinking and there I am
going and so we'd love to have this be
an experience that enriches your
ministry in as many ways as possible so
of course we're blessed to have folks
like Roger nishioka come and speak to us
but it would be lovely also if it was a
time of networking and gathering and
friend making here it would be lovely if
we gathered increasingly resources that
you could reflect upon and take away
from the resource center I'm trying to
recruit our bookstore to have the kind
of collection that would be generative
for folks here and then displayed in
case you wanted to take some books home
so
the one stop shopping multitasking is
where we're moving toward and Carolyn
thank you for bringing the Resource
Center material down here today I always
want to make a an invitation for you to
join our youth ministry now Facebook
page because it's so critical when chap
Clark came down with pneumonia just
before the last talk and we did
everything we could to communicate with
our folks but man I'd hate to think of
somebody driving down here from
Glastonbury not knowing that our talk
was cancelled or not knowing about the
opportunity so please check us out and
like the page similarly all these
lectures are on the youth ministry
initiative dot org site and an
additional resource that we're putting
their we we will make Roger not only
sing for his supper with the lecture but
when we're done here we'll go down to
the yale broadcast studios and we'll do
eight and nine minute clips on targeted
questions that are real boots on the
ground questions of youth ministry all
those clips are both on youtube in our
channel and accessible by the youth
ministry initiative dot org website so
that's an additional resource for you to
reflect upon finally next month january
we're trying to do this the first
tuesday of each month so it's just
something to think about and look
forward to the students won't be here
the first week of january next month and
so we didn't really want to make
somebody travel in for that day but
we're going to hold it and i'm going to
throw my body into the fray what i'll be
speaking about next month is youth
ministry mission trip as pilgrimage how
to get out of the idea of that we often
bring in and understand it's a
pilgrimage of transformation both for us
and the people we partnership and it
will be intensely oriented towards the
nuts and bolts and practicalities as
well as the theology of mission trips
i've been blessed to be on forty mission
trips over the last twenty years so all
my mistakes i will bring to you sir no
don't have to necessarily make the same
mistakes and then i'm sorry I do have
one additional thing one of the one of
the initiatives that we found that has
been really extraordinary is a program
we call youth ministry initiative
fellows we've been able to raise some
money to supplement what we
compensate interns with for placements
in local churches and we are glad to
drive this supplemental compensation as
tuition stipend into any traditions or
any church that is willing to support a
vibrant youth ministry at their church
and I know I have some of our this
year's fellows today could i ask this
year's fellows who are here to stand all
right these are our youth ministry
initiative fellows for this year they're
yd as students they happen to be placed
at our church this year but we would
love to support placements into your
churches thank you Kendra and Kelsey and
what we would like to see is you're
interested in youth ministry you're
prepared to support it with some
vibrancy whatever the scale and size at
your church in your tradition will
provide the tuition support to
supplement your compensation and then
we'll gather them up here together on
tuesday nights or something for
reflection together what they're
learning in youth ministry so look for
that youth ministry initiative fellows
program and if you're interested for
your church come see all right i am
delighted time well i'm only taking time
away from rogers presentation so i'm
going to stop doing that okay if you
were here last year you already know
this is a real real treasure of the
church Roger nishioka combines
extraordinary experiences and passions
he is one of our country's renowned and
respected academics and researchers and
thought leaders on the question of youth
ministry and young adult ministry and
Christian education he is committed to
our denominational health spending ten
years coordinating youth ministries for
the Presbyterian Church USA right now
and Roger runs a youth group on sunday
nights how great is this resource to the
church his current work that he's
working toward for the international
association in support of youth
ministries is on the question of
resilience and imagination and our young
nurturing and among our ministers and
then nurturing in the morning are young
he was an amazing guest last year and
gave us a really generative talk and we
are delighted to welcome Roger nishio
he is the Benton family associate
professor of Christian education at
Columbia Theological Seminary Roger
welcome back hey Wow so the Reverend
mass back is exactly right that the gift
for the year 2012 and beyond right the
amazing gift is not about Facebook stock
the amazing gift the precious treasure
for the year 2012 is people's time if
people gift you with time then that's a
remarkable thing and all you can do the
best you can do you and I is to hold
that as precious and important so I know
you're busy folks thank you for
traveling near and far to get here and
to be a part of the conversation
honestly it inspires me does my heart
good anytime I see folks who are
interested want to have further
conversation about how we care for young
people the whole church in these days
young people and families these days so
I teach at a place called Columbia
seminary in Decatur Georgia down in
Atlanta it's a my own traditions
Presbyterian as you heard skip tell you
so that's sort of the lens through which
I'm coming at these days what I want to
do on the task given to me has been to
talk for about 45 minutes or so about
experiential youth ministry and it seems
to me the best way for us to do this is
for me not just to talk about it but for
us to actually try and act to this in
some way so I've got handouts coming to
you for text and for some questions that
we'll talk about in a moment so there
will be some handouts coming to your
tables and then questions and no Kelly's
got them come they're coming unless you
brought Bibles with you but why would
you if you're episcopalian so anyway um
so see a little good you have a ipad
you're fit your checking facebook right
now aren't you i know you are ok very
good thank you and you can tweet if you
want to that really is ok so there's
text coming around so i want to start
with some quick conversation with you
and with me we know that the best way to
study you study the bible interesting
the Bible keeps on showing up huge skip
told
do I do research on youth and young
adults I just finished a major research
project on young adults asking the
question why are so few young adults
that we have baptized often and
confirmed it depends on your tradition
staying with us in the mainline churches
these are Episcopalian United Methodist
christian church disciples of christ
united church of christ presbyterian
lutheran etc very very few are staying
in our churches I asked the question why
there's a whole series of conversations
we can have about young adult ministry
twenty and thirtysomethings but I can
tell you this that when I did ask what
do you want us to talk about what do you
want us to steady if you spend time with
us do you want us to do a Oprah's Book
Club a type thing so we talked about
some kind of cool event happening around
and they said actually we would love if
you would help us study bible bible
showed up as number one choice among
young adults searched and unchurched
they're intrigued by it they know
something about it they know they don't
know enough about it and these are not
just church people these are people who
are unchurched as well we know that in
turns to the best setting for bible
study for the most part small groups
eight to ten persons work best so you're
going to function either at a table
today or half a table because the
poinsettias lovely as they are in the
way so you may want to be half a table
each group needs a leader facilitator
and the process is not a secret and so I
want to introduce to you in the next 45
minutes to processes and dig deeply into
one part of the process which is
question asking and question delivering
so two processes potential processes for
youth ministry in signing the Bible and
then we'll talk more deeply about the
questions that we use in discussion okay
so interestingly enough i just finished
a interview with Bill Hybels who
arguably I would argue probably is the
founder of the megachurch movement in
America Bill Hybels is the founding
pastor of do you know yeah Willow Creek
he founded Willow Creek out of South
Barrington Illinois golly membership is
a dubious question the mega churches
call membership different things and
i'll call membership and different
but we're talking about 35 40 thousand
people or so in the world creek church
there in South Barrington Illinois
interestingly enough mega churches like
willow creek and others are beginning to
dismantle their what they call seeker
friendly services they built their whole
ministry upon you all come in the South
those of us who come from the south it's
called y'all come I was in Mississippi
recently preaching at one of our
Presbyterian churches and the
announcement from the pastor he said
later on there's a gathering for all
y'all I told him excuse me I i come from
honolulu in seattle but i think that's
redundant he said no son all y'all is
different from y'all anyway so this
whole idea of seeker friendly services
gathering thousands upon thousands of
folks every sunday they're actually
having a tough time these megachurches
holding on to their numbers tell me why
ah nice relationality the whole idea is
people say they get tired of sitting
sunday after sunday next to people whom
they don't know no one asks them hey so
how did that application go for grad
school how the promotion go how is that
date last Thursday etc okay willow creek
and other churches i also interviewed
rick warren at Saddleback churches as
well they're dismantling their seeker
friendly services in favor of do you
know small group ministry they're moving
to small group ministry that's kind of a
cool thing because frankly some of us
our parishes are small groups
so I'm like cool we're already there
were contemporary didn't even know it
okay he said the problem is the reason
why in their research they do so they
did say that a lot of their seekers who
come to a church setting for a while do
find their way they try actually coming
to a united methodist a presbyterian
episcopal etc church and they look
around us two things happen number one
is they find a worship service that
doesn't have any passion or life to it
secondly they're desperate for
relationships and they come in and
either they get assaulted which is not
helpful or they get ignored which is
also not helpful and so then he says by
and large you people mess up we've
already messed up and that's why the
vast majority of twenty thirty
something's in the United States on
Sunday mornings are art at st. mattress
there are no we're okay like a normal
people should be looking good coffee
okay having decent bagels and reading
the paper all right so so that's the
dilemma for us what's interesting for me
is we know bible study works best in
small group settings the small group
setting is already being celebrated and
affirmed by these megachurches they're
dismantling their big huge mega churches
and going to small group settings when i
walked into the last worship service
recently about a month and a half ago in
South Barrington Illinois the first
thing they asked me was what is your zip
code and I said 3003 thinking okay 3003
and they said sure just a moment and a
young woman came and guided me to a room
of other people who have similar 300 300
s there were 14 people from the Greater
Atlanta area who were worshipping there
that day two of them live in decatur
which is where i live one of them lism
mile and a half away from me and we had
this lovely conversation we were led by
a facilitator and their hope is that we
would gather on a regular basis in the
Greater Atlanta area they've got these
small groups meeting where
in homes worshiping studying eating
together praying on a regular basis
sounds just like first and second
century Church so the conversation among
church historians right now is that the
21st century Church likely has more in
common with the first and second century
Church that it does with a twentieth
century church and we have to reorient
ourselves and so I'm reading Acts of the
Apostles in a whole new way I'm looking
at the Paul's epistles in a whole new
way still suspicious of the Ephesians
church emphasis is just as people are
just too nice okay the Corinthian church
I know that church I served that church
several times okay but anyway so i'm
reading the Acts of the Apostles Iranian
Paul's epistles in whole new ways and I
think it's worthy of our attention so
and the best thing is for us to Judas
and small group conversations right okay
what you're going to do in a moment what
I want to do is propose a real real
simple model for the first one a
framework for experiential bible study
the framework does this is just three
simple steps it's of what as in what is
the background of the passage so what
why is this important and now what how
do i live faithfully as a result of this
study so think about a framework for
bible study as what think about it as so
what think about it is now what that's
all i want you to think about okay what
so what now what if you frame a 45
minute bible study or 35 minute bible
study or 20 minute bible study with
middle schoolers if you frame it as a
what as a soph what and now what you're
doing really really well interestingly
enough seminarians from yale div school
it's been a heck of a lot of times on
what
we love doing the what okay our young
people are desperate for so what and now
what we like the problem is Oh golly our
times up and I just gave you a 20 minute
mini lecture on the Greek and the Hebrew
here I'm so sorry and they walk out
thinking okay well that was interesting
so this happens over and over again that
the what is interesting but we can't
spend all of our time on the what all
right either at your half table or at
the whole table probably know try half
table if you would okay so you're going
to work on text for me please this is
the call of Samuel and if so if you
would just have some voices read aloud
on the call of Samuel and just go around
your table and just hear different
voices if you would take just a few
moments and go ahead and read the
passage
Oh
so friends the word of the Lord that's
not you minimize your tradition my
tradition says the word of the Lord and
the response from the congregation is
thanks be to god the word of the Lord
tell me one of the kinds of things that
would be important for you to talk about
in a what what are the kinds of things
this is background stuff what is the
background what kind of background
things are important for you to share
with a group of young people about the
what please Oh lovely why was he line
living there at the temple so the role
of eli who is eli and why is he there at
the temple lovely please was a time when
God people are free from Egypt from
captivity etc but they don't have a king
you don't have a leader necessarily
nicely done thank you what else please
well who is Samuel asking the question
who is samuel was a lovely story about
samuel son of hannah who was barren for
years and she said lord give me a trial
that i will give it to you so Samuel is
given as a boy to be an assistant to the
priest ok anything else that selects the
duty was the thing is important please
what why is the word of the Lord
contrast ah lovely that great praise the
word of the Lord was rare in those days
visions were not widespread lovely thank
you other what's what did Eli sons do
that he needed to be punished so so part
of the what especially if i'm doing
middle schoolers is there are some
vocabulary issues i want to work on
right away vocabulary words like what a
68 but that is excavated
okay so just do some natural word stuff
okay expiated without another word stuff
anything else that you want to ask me
what uh so the Dean thank you what you
know something about personally so yeah
so the day of the berkeley school says
dean britain says blaspheme what the
heck does blasphemy so part of the what
is working with young people to get some
of the vocabulary going ok in other
what's that you think are important
beersheba yeah dan to air Sheba what the
heck is that thank you nicely done
anything else other language issues
please oh what's a profit well then I
would invite the young people to ask
their what's when you when you hear this
what do you wonder about lovely so so in
my process working with my youth group
at central presbyterian church in
Atlanta I'll just I'll just ask question
like what are the questions that you
have and have them generate those kinds
of questions I'll put them on the board
I won't get to all of them because if I
all I do in 45 minutes is start working
on those questions all I'm gonna do is
step one but I've missed out entirely on
the sofa and then now what which happens
over and over again in Bible study which
is why our young people on our adults
say bible study is because it doesn't
have any relevance to my life that's
your fault okay don't let them say that
because you have to do all the what's
all the time all right and what a
discover it is as long as you put
something on a piece of paper or on a
white board as long as a question goes
up there thats that actually gives it
away and the group says ok at least I
was heard which is the most important
thing I was heard and you can say we're
not going to get to all these questions
these are great questions we're not
going to get to all of them could we
have to move on to the silhouette and
then now what in the youth room and
central presbyterian church it says the
Bible study this is not a secret process
it says bible study process what so what
now what this is not hard we have it
painted on the wall ok and so we're at
the point now where I've got young
people who can lead each other okay okay
turn to turn to your small groups do the
white and they have these conversations
in there and we generate these lists all
right
and then we do the silhouettes and then
we do the now what's all right anything
else only do about the what please Dean
oh ok now you're meddling Dean Britain
says this wouldn't be a bad model for
preaching I think you're exactly right I
think we tend to do it in the preaching
process a lot of the what and we don't
tell our people why does this is what
we're talking about this at all in these
days thank you that's a nice turn
anything else want to say about the
what's that are important please oh I
got a contextual definition Kali lat
great language contextual definition of
sacrifice lovely exactly okay um the the
caution for Roger every single time is
I've got to be careful because I can
take this and go I can do the what's
forever in there this is fascinating
stuff I love this I can pull out
commentaries I can do language studies
because I'm smart and intelligent I have
a degree in seminary so this is this is
great stuff okay but my worry is it ends
up being really about Roger being able
to show you how much he knows and that
isn't the point of the text the point of
the text is that God we dared to believe
that God somehow reveals God's self to
us in these days okay the precious gift
of time you honor it so I also make one
it makes it a little bit experiential
and so I'll do a little bit of I'll do
some call stuff this is called the call
of Samuel and call language house has to
also be sort of decipher at some point
but 2003-2004 2005 I think for what two
seasons right sorry a sitcom ran more of
a sitcom sort of Joan of Arcadia and so
this is a young woman I would want to
use something that's more contemporary I
want I want them to sort of experience
the text so they've read the text and
they've heard it we had some
conversation about some of the what's
but I want to sort of experience the
text in a different way so this is the
opening scene from the pilot the whole
premise
have you seen this show anybody seen
this show it didn't last for two both
more than two seasons I think there's
some reasons why we talking about that
some other time but it's fascinating so
this young woman Joan here's God and
this is the pilot and this is the start
of her hearing her father is Chief of
Police of Arcadia and what they do is
they jux to pose in this pilot the
opening Joan who is his daughter she has
an older brother who was hurt in a car
accident she has a younger brother Luke
who is a nerd science nerd em she has
mom and dad her dad's Chief of Police of
Arcadia and Joan here's a call from God
and so this is the pilot and the
juxtapose Joan hearing a call with the
killing of a young woman Jones age
perhaps in the area there in Arcadia so
a couple clips
chief I didn't mean hands come down
which is calling let you know but I
related we don't know you so I know you
ride either not yet more persuasive
float to show her calling this the guys
who as an offical trust him yeah I
wouldn't want him to think that officer
you get a picture of this what book
print Osborne get over follow that movie
certainly Emmy just arrived wait a
minute the medical examiner is just
getting you yes searching so tell me she
was fun with that blanket already on
well no sir she was just lying there on
the opening you've contaminated the
scene officer and its procedure 101 I'm
sorry sir just just go again he's not
homicide is the officer on patrol luck
of the draw he's a cop as a neat pass
the exam get your own I'm gonna take
care if i can just reiterate in show up
on teen murder investigation and
undagger when these investigations
become routine I won't have to show up
anymore
ciao
so that so the scene continues and she
heard her voice being called and woke up
as a result and then she and so the
scene opens and you need to begin to get
the credits etc and then it goes into a
conversation at breakfast the whole
premise for the film is that Joan is
called by god but God appears to her in
a variety of personas ok and this is
called cute boy God because she first
meets God as a cute guy on the bus going
to school and he follows her to school
she doesn't know him because she doesn't
recognize him and he's a cute kid it's
what she would recognize him and so this
is the next conversation that they have
when God reveals God's self to Joan he
loves me so I gotta warn you my dad's a
cop it's not just any cop he's the cop I
know who your father is Joan he's full
Girardi's born September fourth 1955
Chicago his father was Gerald Girardi
his mother was on Monroe he had an
uneventful childhood tended mother
cabrini high school in wharton junior
college after that adjourned the police
force in 1980 he met your mother when
Helen Brody shows an art school dropout
here the middle child of three about a
year and a half ago year older brother
kevin was in a car accident fractured
his back after my paraplegic hit one
other brother Luke was 15 my favorite
coach green you love salt on cantaloupe
Jim das broke your heart in eighth grade
they afraid of clowns
who are you
I've known me since before you're a born
John Knicely one more time I'm God
what God
don't ever talk to me again
okay so so the whole series is based
upon these kinds of conversations where
God appears in different personas
speaking to Joan and talking to her and
calling her to do certain things and to
be about a certain way of living so an
experiential bible study what I would do
next is after reading the text doing
somewhat work I would want to show a
clip like this that makes the call story
the themes that emerged a little more
contemporary in some ways tell me the
value of this think about in your head
why why that would be valuable for
adolescents in these days that's okay
that's okay that's okay go ahead and
tell me just a different media lovely
it's a different media source exactly
please it does too nice it does change
the tentacle so part of what I do I
teach teaching I I tell my students my
job is to help you be a better teacher
when you leave my classroom at Columbia
seminary my job that help you be a
better teacher teacher of the Bible
teacher of new members classes teacher
of confirmation teach a class on
confirmation journey etc whatever it is
and so part of what I realized is I'm
talking about five to seven minute
increments in terms of teaching patterns
younger adolescents three to four
minutes squirrel because um because uh
attention wise they're going to be gone
okay but five to seven minutes is pretty
long so I'm training up intentionally I
don't want it I don't want to presume we
can sit here and do 25 minutes of just
looking at a text I want to take them to
a visual source we also know from the
brain research five senses okay the
sense that engages the least amount of
brain power hearing the sense that
engages the most brain power visual I
thought I thought to be kiddin cited to
bodily touching but it's actually visual
the sense that has the strongest
remembering
of the five olfactory smell so so the
whole idea for you and for me is
anything i can show okay young people i
know that their brain power is going to
be engaged in a whole different way
interestingly enough I'm back to Dean
Britain's fine point a lot of our
worship engages hearing the least amount
of brain power we don't see very much we
don't smell some of a smell sometimes
not good things but I'm where I'm
smelling etc let alone tasting and
touching okay so there's a reason why I
would change it up and I would want them
to do to experience sort of a new way of
seeing the text so the silhouette why
this is important the now what all right
so what I wonder how I want to get to
these is I want to get to these through
discussion questions so the second hand
out on your on your sheet on your table
right so a friend of mine who teaches at
a little school down in New Jersey their
poor small begins with a pea ok so
anyway Rick Hosmer teaches at Princeton
Theological Seminary he's a great great
guy despite teaching at Princeton and he
says they're four methods for forming
discussion questions I realize a lot of
what we do is we have discussions about
the text which is actually fine and
that's a great way to get to the sofa
and then now what but but the kinds of
questions you ask and the way you ask
questions there is some curriculum out
there that is really really stupid bible
study curriculum because their questions
are so poor okay your job as a leader of
the text is to be able to engage our
students are young people our children
are older adults or middle-aged adults
in the nature of question asking okay
osmar says factual questions and litical
questions productive questions and
evaluative questions so coming down
factual questions
questions one asks for information
they're the narrowest of questions they
have a single right answer not as
difficult or threatening as offering
opinions or insights for example who is
Jesus's mother Martha and thank you for
playing you're wrong okay we're with
Jesus born Chicago and thank you for
playing no he's not a Bears fan that
would be sacrilegious okay to analytical
questions asked persons to analyze
information and draw conclusions about
it moves beyond simple recall teachers
have an answer or range of answers in
mind builds on factual takes more time
than factual questions to be prepared
for longer pauses what is the role of
the poor and the Gospel of Luke what are
some of the theological differences
between infant baptism and believers
baptism you have a range of answers in
mind the difference between factual and
analytical is you have one answer for
factual and you have a range of answers
for analytical okay then it goes to
productive open-ended does not see a
correct answer based on learners
creativity there's no one right answer
there actually it's just the learner is
up to the learner you can't say no
that's not correct so factual and
analytical there's either a one correct
answer or a range of answers productive
it's wide open okay and then you move to
evaluative ask questions to make a value
judgment stick a claim no one right
answer broaden open and it takes more
thinking time health persons become
aware of the standards they apply when
responding to an evaluative question
examples what are the most important
teachings of the Bible what are the five
key characteristics that make for a good
minister what was your most significant
moment in your faith journey okay the
difference being productive and
evaluative you can see it evaluative is
forcing the young person to make a claim
all right so quickly either the half
table or the whole table from this text
come up with one factual one analytical
one productive and one evaluative and
somebody record please
or something like this gosh hey they
just say you'll have other answers other
ideas maybe yeah sort of maybe
introducing the idea that there you know
in this kind of question unlike a
factual question this is one of those
questions were there are multiple
answers and so I really appreciate your
input does anybody else have some ideas
another question about why yeah let me
get you in hey um so if you would
reporter to somebody give us give us
give us a few factual please a few
factual questions please who are the
characters in the story ah nice who are
the characters in the story a right
answer wrong answer Clippers are clearly
there's clearly a right answer wrong
answer nicely done other factual what is
it arc excellent which is totally cool
because we're gonna get some young
people who are going to say it's a boat
but Noah built which is a lovely way if
you get into well it could be it also
can be a geometry shape etc is in the
arc of history said Martin Luther King
Bennett or justice but it also could be
the place where the Covenant is kept i
said i did not see Raiders of the Lost
Ark come on be conversant here that's
the last century I know what's still
factual that's how many times the Lord
call Samuel lovely factual question
anything else other factions who called
Samuel who nice nice nice anything else
okay do analytical police range of
answers why do you think God called
Samuel so many times oh that's lovely
Wow range of answers in your head
in my mind borderline could be
productive yeah but I love the question
it's not wrong it's a great question I
can see it both analytical and
productive differences range of answers
in your head because my 13 year old says
well because obviously Samuel has a
hearing deficiency you said well we're
in the text does that say that so I
think that could be analytical that that
doesn't that isn't the point so thank
you nicely done other analyticals blows
the roles that profits not only nicely
done going to Eli why does he keep going
to eli blue that's great that's great
let's make what while it was Samuel
confused please draw a video a little
bit how did the two colleagues different
oh nice so you can do an analytical
based upon the video clip and say how do
the two Colleen's differ oh that's
lovely what are you drinking oh really
is that a mini keg are you to piss
capelean your methodist yeah close yeah
okay fine anything else I Van Winkle's
okay nice then go to productive please
Oh lovely fantastic what are some ways
that you have heard God big difference
is you can't say the young person if you
know you haven't heard God that way to
stop possible okay but but brace
yourself because they can say all kinds
of things and that's entirely possible
lovely other productive questions please
Christy oh great follow-up have you ever
rejected a call from God and what
happened oh man that's that's a good
stuff please response to God p what my
sandals response to God be our thinking
was that framings think about it what
like someone else's responses be and it
was stepping stone to then ask them or
directly or depending on where you know
that students at say then what would
your response be oh I love about that so
what what are some possible responses
what that does is so the whole point of
adolescence right is called egocentrism
which is the world revolves around nice
that's supposed to end at some point you
know that just checking okay so it's all
about me yeah you're here to serve me
okay um narcissism but the whole idea
yeah but then you move that you move
that in a lovely way you start pushing
them outside themselves okay the reason
why your mama said to you well honey put
yourself in someone else's shoes and of
course is a concrete thinker eight years
old you're thinking will that be stinky
because he has bad feet kind of thing
okay but the reason why your mama said
that was she's trying to push you out of
your ego centrism which is the task of
growing up all right maturing I'm so in
a lovely way right away you move them
out of themselves but then you focus on
themselves as well so at this table
we're talking about factual lend
themselves to what okay the first sorry
the what the what part of the state
okay sorry yeah it was on second Oh what
okay analyticals productive and
evaluative lend themselves to moving
toward do you see it the silhouettes and
the now let's ok portion of your study
the hardest one any valiant if questions
you want to test with the group please
determine whether what you're hearing is
God determine it could be really a call
fantastic how do you determine what
you're hearing is really a call from God
evaluative it can get there I I think
initially its productive tell me why
because there's a there's not really
that's right so that works out fine and
there's a wide range force that is a
great question for snap to be evaluative
make the young person make a claim how
do you know what it's a call from god
you're getting there i agree with you i
think that borders on evaluative ooh
emphasizing the you how do you how would
you know that's true or your call nicely
done or what is called god called you
also that's nice i would force it even
more i would say what is the most in
what is the most significant way you've
discovered that you know god's calling
do you see the evaluative i put in there
i forced into have to choose what the
most significant one of my best friends
from seminary he's got two teenagers the
question that they hate and they he
asked him every day and they hate john
they they come home and he's like so
what was the best thing that happened
today I hate that question dad okay
there's an evaluative question as
opposed to what swinging that happened
today that's productive what's the best
thing happened today forces the kid to
make a claim why is making a claim
important it takes time you do it the
process thank you
Steve helps make it yours it does
stephen says it makes it it makes them
own it it isn't just some nice answer it
make this is the now what this is the so
what about me this is this is it forces
them up interesting Lee enough in my
survey I teach a curriculum course also
a survey of curriculum through school
curriculum and when I look at discussion
questions for adolescent curriculum we
spend a heck of a lot of time asking
what kinds of questions we do a lot of
factual curriculum writers do a lot of
factual questions and a lot of
analyticals I see almost no I by my
estimation less than three percent were
evaluative questions only about fifteen
percent were productive questions why
they require imagination it's scary and
if you are writing a curriculum you want
to be able to say expect answers like
these kinds of things okay the problem
is we know we know that does not move
our young people to an engagement of the
text that answers the sofa and the now
what question of their lives what does
this text possibly have to say to me how
can this text possibly have any meaning
for my life please buy it basically when
you were just saying that the first two
categories are more about the text a
second two categories or more about us
lovely and we confuse bible study for
being a study about the bible as opposed
to being a study about lovely lovely a
language to tell me your name jack says
the first two questions i don't talk
about that but i think you're right on
it jack says the first two questions
tend to be a bible study about the text
itself which is not a bad thing right
when the latter two questions the
productivity value actually forced a
question about us our engagement with
the text and it's easier to engage the
text from a distance as it is to have to
live in the text ourselves oh that's
lovely thank you I agree ok I think it's
scarier I think it's scarier I think
it's harder please some teachers are
more comfortable feeling they're in
control of what's going to happen next
and they're not will
to give up that control so they don't
ask the productive and evaluative
question golly that never happens in my
seminary but you're brilliant tell me
your name Linda you're on it I I think I
think out of our fearfulness that we
have to be in control of these moments
and not the Holy Spirit who's at work in
us for us through us sometimes by the
grace of God in spite of us that yeah we
want to control this and we think we
should have the answers so we want the
factual questions the analytical at the
most and we had those already prepared
and we can answer so we can show how
bright we are one of my best friends
just interviewed for a position at one
of our seminaries and the question that
the president asked her and he always
asks his question apparently he said
would you rather professor if you're if
we call you be a professor here would
you rather be boring or would you rather
be wrong and so she texted me and said
how would you answer this question it
wasn't during the interview it was
afterwards and so I i was talking to
aaron and i said what did you say and
she said well I said to the committee
well i think i think i would rather be
wrong because if I was boring my
students probably wouldn't even pay
attention to me and I've been doing a
grave and just in the you know the
service to the text into to theology
into the whole point of study and and so
I think I'd rather be wrong than be
boring because I think we can always try
it in next classes figure out how to do
right and right now as I'm speaking it
occurs to me I probably have succeeded
in doing both
and she hasn't gotten a call back but
it's a brilliant brilliant that's an
invited to a question would you rather
be wrong in what you got to be boring
that's mean by it to a question it's
forced choice please I think I'll just
coming out of like mainline
denominations it's uncomfortable to ever
asked like do for like faith claim
because you have people who are the
church from all different backgrounds
it's like places on Christian journey so
it's a comfortable for a leader to be
like well what do you actually believe
versus what do you know we know the
right file exciting the answers we want
what do you but like you're and I
appreciate your moniker and I think
you're exactly right holding the mirror
up to those of us who come from these
mainline traditions here's my take on
that I think we have misconstrued this
faith in Jesus Christ I think we think
that faith in Jesus Christ is supposed
to be private our faith in Jesus Christ
is not private it is personal but it is
not private if it was private we
wouldn't have to do this we would have
to come together and give up time and
drive in the rain for a sandwich
inducted to each other about the Bible
we could be in doing our own individual
mean Jesus praise time things etc which
would be lovely cuz it's all about me
and meeting my needs ok we have
misconstrued this idea that your faith
in Jesus Christ is private it's not
private it is personal but it's not
private I think you're exactly right the
interesting thing is I think young
people are yearning for an opportunity
to stick a claim to what is true and
more importantly they want to know what
you believe to be true not in a way
that's oppressive or coercive or
manipulative it's very clear in my
research that they don't want bible
study where someone gets up and says
this is what it means therefore say this
ok what they want is for you to open the
text up and to do a what so what now
what to ask the kind of questions that
generate meaning from my life I think
we're meaning makers it's what what it
means to be called in the image of God
that we've created as someone who seeks
me it's our nature to seek meaning
please I think that one of the other
reasons that it's hard is that these
kinds of questions require youth to take
more time and think about it pletely and
challenges them in a way that most of
them aren't challenged on a regular
basis yeah and so when you're the one
teaching and they're all looking at you
13 confer man's yeah with these totally
blank stares and you're like are they
gonna keep staring at me exactly it's
been a minute and a half now it's been
what what and you want to jump in you
want to like save them or rescue the
Holy do as it and they start looking at
each other and they're just waiting for
somebody to speak up and so I think that
it it takes longer to let it happen um
and that silence gets scary for us as
leaders yeah for them as youth sort of
all across the border beautifully tell
me your name Lorraine Lorraine that's
beautifully said and gets back to Linda
your control issue that where'd Linda go
she's gone I'm the Linda's control issue
Oh rapture and we're all still here see
I knew get left behind so yes so
Lorraine's on it I think it's a control
issue I think the whole bottom line for
us is that tell me I'm tell me your name
scooby-doo Karen Karen tell us tell us
about your scooby-doofus let's go do
whatever they later can you hear that
and so stable karen was saying yeah my
kids have a scooby-doo moment the other
issue for our young people is when we
look at American schooling by and large
some of our most successful young people
are successful in American schooling
because they have learned to say back to
the teacher what what the teacher wants
to hear so when we give them a
productive and then an evaluative
question their first thought their modus
operandi 'it laureen's on it is they're
like wait a minute what but what do you
want us to say and that's what they've
been they've been awarded for that and
rewarded for that
and it's unnerving for them to realize
that they have some sense of voice and
some sense of power and they can
actually bring their own knowing to the
text itself lovely please someone said
go incident that thinking like stare
moment a summer camp Holly Todd Lee of
physical exercise forgetting is to move
which which is an embodiment evaluate
question that you're talking about us
which is creating a line room and saying
if you want your setup and it forces
them literally their bodies which is
phenomenal a great idea especially for
early adolescence to actually move I've
called I call those forced choice
spectrums and we put that a spectrum
lily I put tape on the floor and say
okay and so you decide and we'd love to
move and then we have a nice top where
they are and we have a conversation
about it when they realize there are the
people on different sides of the room so
I think that's lovely please what they
say hm are you like I believe it I think
that's one these wives be kind of avoid
those questions and in up tailors that
conversation and then
exactly it doesn't go anywhere your your
language is fantastic jameelah says un
bling it doesn't go anywhere you're
exactly right but but they have been
schooled and this is the process and
they walk out saying okay fine so I get
so my password jameelah she's just like
my school teacher etc so I get it this
is how I operate it at church totally
totally totally right exactly exactly
exactly I think points well taken please
I think one of the key factors from me
in ministry is understanding that I
assume sometimes the youth will trust us
yes but building your trust is critical
in the process golly because I'm gonna
answer a question that you're asking of
me i'm going to assume that you're gonna
want to curate yep or if i'm going to
push back and you don't want to hear it
yeah i have to trust that you're going
to see that answer well said so so every
so I was telling skip and Jonah at
breakfast and Eileen at breakfast this
morning yesterday I was I'm on the
faculty evaluation committee for
Columbia seminary as a colleague who's
up for tenure and so my job was to be in
his classroom yesterday and I was
watching him teach and what I noticed is
in his classroom this is a fine fine
colleague and I'm sure I think he'll get
tenure and but what I realized is when
he opens up the floor for conversation a
student says something a student says
something and he he stands there okay
now the next thing is all right and and
so I literally drew a class a classroom
map and I was checking off how many
times students say something okay and
each time a student says something and
gets no response from him they stopped
speaking they didn't they didn't say
anything again it doesn't have to be
that everything you say is oh gift from
the Holy Spirit of it okay but but all
we're asking is can you build trust
levels enough that is jamila said you
can actually venture something that's
kind of scary and isn't going to be
honored okay and that's the question
that's being asked so I think I've back
to Lorraine I think the other reason why
they're looking at us
they're trying to see do you really want
to know what I think or do I play the
game again and tell you what I think you
want me to say because I can do that
that's her what is it you want me to
keep exactly what's the right answer
exactly and I'm caught and pushed back
from young people in this process who've
been saying well what you know what's
the answer and I said it was a
productive question and so I've actually
taught them Ozma's production question
frames and they've actually used it
ladies language now my high schoolers do
more in the middle scores but they say
is that an evaluative or productive and
like I think it's a little bit of both
all right okay just checking because
they want to know what are the rules
around this question um finish up
there's one more that I'll talk to you
just about briefly that this is making
it circles that I think is really
interesting there's a conversation right
now in some bible studying methods
talking about behind the text in the
text and in front of the text it's a
nuance I think in some ways of neck what
so what and now what but it's a little
bit different the behind the text
question talks about the context if
you're a fill out a trained person you
would hear the historical critical
method in this you're looking for
background okay so whenever you read any
kind of text and you want to look behind
the text you're looking at what is the
context for the text what's the
background work in the text looks at the
text itself content of the text it's
more of a literary criticism they look
at just the pure text itself as if the
text stands on its own okay the passage
stands on its own you're not concerned
about the historical the archaeological
the anthropological the timeframe just
one look at the text itself the passage
itself and then in front of the text
locating oneself as a reader of the text
how one's context influences one's
reading a reader response if you will
those are three kinds of criticism
criticism meaning ways of reading the
text historical-critical literary and
and reader response each of them have
some strength each of them have some
some benefits and some possibilities but
think
about one other method I told you I give
you two the first one is what so what
now what the second one is thinking
about behind the text the text itself in
the text and in front of the text as a
possibility if you want to frame study
that way it's also possible to do okay
um please jack lovely jack says in front
of the text also is how the text has
been used since it's been written used
and abused in some cases oh that's nice
thank you thank you what makes this
experiential young people say they've
experienced something when they engage
more than one sent simultaneously so
part of my reason for showing you a clip
was I didn't want to just do a piece of
paper I didn't want to just do I'm
hearing I wanted to actually see
something okay so we're talking about
experiential learning experiential Bible
study it's engaging more than one sense
Simon experiential worship okay
experiencing God I'm desperate for an
experienced the Lord then you're able to
provide more than one sense at a time
engage more than one sense at a time
okay so who's been to the Holy Land
please raise your hand thank you so when
you get off the plane to orlando and you
go to disney world what you're going to
end up with is you're going to see in
disney world there's the magic kingdom
there's animal kingdom etc at Epcot
there's a place oh you thought it was
Jerusalem no no no um so um Epcot has a
ride called soaring okay it originated
in California which is the true Holy
Land Disneyland ok california adventure
and it's an experience of california
anybody been on soaring or sworn over
California have you okay this is totally
pirated all right it's a fake Disney
hang gliding ride okay where they strap
you in to these rows and they lift you
up off the floor and your feet are
dangling and you see this huge screen in
front of you there's a wonderful
soundtrack there's air going etc and
and it's an experience of Cal it's
called Soarin over California your hang
gliding over California okay this is
totally pirated
okay so what happens is as you're going
over as you're doing these things in k
the the ride is tilting as well okay as
you go over the Rogue River in northern
california and these evergreens they
insert into the theater the smell of
evergreen okay I mean when you go over a
big certain little while they um they
missed water into the theater okay
you're going to go over the imperial
valley central california orange groves
they squirt into the theater the smell
of oranges Disney is saying you're going
to walk out after five and a half
minutes and you're going to have an
experience of California you're going to
feel like you were in California because
they know how to engage more than one
sense at a time what I'm hoping is that
you and I take seriously the opportunity
in Bible study to make it experiential
which means that you engage more than
one sense at a time okay so one of my
current students named courtney and you
know this has to be a call from the lord
because she left a great job she was an
Imagineer in Orlando and left a stupid
woman and left that job to come to
columbia seminary studied be a
Presbyterian pastor this one was
delusional um and I was talking to her
about this in one of my classes and
shaking up afterwards and she said I
actually worked on some of that
development for that when it came to
Orlando from California and I said
really and she said you know we were
trying to get the fifth sense we wanted
to get all five simultaneously we were
trying to get taste and I said really it
goes yeah we tried for a year and a half
that's what were you doing and she said
we tried to give people a piece of candy
when they walked in and they put a candy
in their mouth so that as they're going
on this ride as their bodies are tilting
as they see this as they hear this as
they smell this as the wind goes and K
as they go over death valley gets hotter
as it go over the Big Sur the mist etc
she said we're trying to get taste as
well salt instead of a taste of oranges
and I said what happened and she said
Roger I need you to know people have
straight face court
too serious she said lead you know
people have totally different suck
factors and I said really and she goes
yeah it's a problem and I said Courtney
I I've served two churches in my life I
work at a seminary I know people suck at
all different levels and she goes yeah
it's hard and she walked away I'm like
you have to get a sense of humor before
you go into a church girlfriend anyway
the whole idea is that Disney is gets it
Disney understands that we're trying to
deliver an experience okay that's what I
want to think about with your
imagination with the text what is a way
for us to engage the text in not just
reading it and discussing it but what
can they see a clip from Joan of Arcadia
what could they smell what could they
taste what could they touch so that so
that they can actually experience the
text itself please curriculum for little
kids yes and it stopped as soon as you
get the high squad I don't know either
oh yeah Reverend says the judges too
childish right the fascinating thing I
think you're exactly right the
fascinating thing is when I do that kind
of stuff with my early adolescence older
adolescents and my adults they thought
they love this stuff um others know this
one I'll bring up Plato in my classes
and Christian education whether the
shape and form a symbol for Christian
education I've got students going
play-doh can I eat this plate no don't
eat that but this whole idea yeah we
live in childhood stuff I think you're
exactly right I think you're exactly
right please Lorraine I'm finding ways
to not only get to hear or see or
whatever but to to get them to move yes
getting getting ways where they can
embody the text lovely today use our
bodies very much in general
you anywhere yep specially not injured
and doing the spectrum thing before they
that stand somewhere and you guys have
to go thank you last thing so I'm a
pastor's kid so this is evidence you can
be a pastor's kid and still of the Lord
takes years of therapy anyway I'm not
kidding anyway um so group was born and
raised in Honolulu and one of my
earliest memories is we had one bathroom
in our house I'm getting up early and
going to the bathroom my father is
reading by a little lamp in living room
in Honolulu he's reading his Bible
earliest memories consistent i go i dead
hi ROG I'm going to the bathroom okay
the bathroom I'm walking back to my bed
and going back to sleep ok ROG you have
a couple of hours i'll wake you up ok
bye dad night raj over and over again i
remember this talk to my older brother
Jason younger brothers and we all
remember dad reading the Bible my father
never stopped and said look son reading
the word of the Lord thanks be to God he
never said that ok he just he's he was
just reading the Bible what I learned
from my father's faithfulness and doing
that is my dad he loves the Bible he
loves the Bible and what I learned from
that is this is syllogistic right it's
so my dad loves me he loves the Bible he
was teaching me to love the Bible as
well I was intrigued intrigued enough
that he was spent all of his time just
constantly reading the Bible I asked my
best friend Jimmy son later on when I
was we moved to Seattle my best friend
Jimmy son his dad was a Boeing engineer
and I said hey Jimmy does your dad like
have a manual oh yeah he's got a whole
bunch of them like huge manuals cool
does he read them all the time no
does he read them early in the morning
by himself no what oh my dad reads his
manual all the time I learned that my
father loves of the Bible bottom line is
I hope our young people know that we
love this we do this not for information
we do this for transformation because it
changes us it changes me it changes you
it's in my heart so I hope that we have
the sense that our young people learn
they just see us because we love this I
love the Bible I love the weight changes
me and transforms my life for better for
worse I mean there are times when I'm
really struggling I'm really struggling
with the text i was telling skip that I
was doing interview with a young woman
and she was talking to me about I was
asking her why she's in one of our
churches remarkable I would you be in
the Presbyterian Church you're young
bright hello and she said she came to
this one church she was looking for a
church and she came to this one church
and she sat down and the pastor got up
and looked at the congregation and said
I have to tell you I've been struggling
with this text for three and a half
weeks and this gentleman said I was on
the edge of the pew I had never heard
someone have the courage one of you
people she said to stand up and have the
courage to say this text from the Bible
is messing with my whole life she said
oh i thought this woman actually is real
honest and real that's what I'm hoping
for I hope that our young people know
that we love the Bible that we love them
hope there are some ways that we can get
to some kind of questions that move
beyond just the knowledge information to
transformation we do that by asking
questions like so what does this have to
do with you now what do you do as a
result of this what does this have to do
with you as you stand in front of the
text so I'm grateful for you and for
your loving and caring for young people
and their families
in our midst let's have a word of Prayer
is that ok let's have a word of Prayer
so we give you thanks O God for the ways
that you care for us let me give you
thanks for your word made flesh in your
son Jesus Christ for whom we await
Christ's coming yet once again and we
give you thanks for your word made known
to us in your scriptures to women and
men faithful generations and for your
holy spirit who somehow after so many
years continues to inspire and transform
and inform so that we might be more
faithful to you bless us even as we seek
to bless and praise you O God for you
alone our maker of the universe until
you be all praise and honor and glory
for you alone are worthy and God's
people say friends Lord be with you
thank you all